okay the procedure is as as usual I will
have Hugh I will make few opening
remarks about faith and human rights
particularly in context of globalization
and then we have two guests who will
serve as our resource persons I again as
we went Oni Blair is here I'm a sidekick
here our two main guests are whatever
they are - even if I'm their side okay
so on the one hand we've observed that
there is this over the past 50 years or
so the spread of the language of human
rights around the globe and some see in
it a new global moral code some even a
new religion but on the other hand we
observed in our readings a contestation
of the meaning of human rights some
rights that were affirmed for instance
very clearly unambiguous again UN
Declaration of Human Rights in 1948 were
kind of attenuated expressed an
attenuated form bit later on and some
scholars I think anacott has mentioned
that in his own recent conversation some
scholars even suggest that were that
declaration on human rights to be voted
today it would not pass all right
because the distinctive the difference
is and on account of more nations coming
into the UN as well as kind of higher
profile of some of the particulars
interest are present present there so on
the one hand you've got a universal
universal language on the other hand
internally very much contested so what
is going on can human rights serve as a
common that common values in our
globalized world how our humanized the
human rights related to particular
religious traditions and communal and
national cultures and maybe the most
fundamental of the of the questions and
some of you have heard me speak that I
think we need to start thinking about
how to formulate issues that we are
addressing here in
forms of very precise fundamental
questions and maybe fundamental question
for us today is first do we need
something like common values in our
globalized world and if we do need
common values what level of commonality
is needed and how to achieve that in our
very much polar allistic world
likelihood of consensus and of course
the question is then significant issues
around the the problem of imposition of
one particular account of those and
professor Clark has addressed some of
these issues so I want to highlight in
my comments here to two areas one is the
question of the universality of human
rights and the other one is relationship
between religion and human rights now in
a sense what you what you have is one
phrase but different meanings and it is
clear that across the globe we don't
mean exactly the same thing when we
speak of human rights we don't use the
phrase uniball univocal mean but we use
also do we use the phrase to mean
completely different things I grew up in
former Yugoslavia communist country and
I know remember it remember during the
Cold War we had this debate about human
rights and understanding of human rights
and in my part of the world it were
understood as positive rights which the
state is supposed to guarantee for you
and then bourgeois account of human
rights as negative rights which you have
over against the state that may be a
case of radically different accounts of
human rights so even there I'm not quite
sure and it may be that we are using the
phrase not exactly in the same way and
not quite in a different way but
something like an analogous way that
there is an overlapping understanding of
how we across the globe use the phrase
human rights
so partial overlaps in the meaning of
that phrase and these partial overlaps
in the meaning of
phrases I think significant because on
the one hand we have in human rights and
the universal claim it's a claim that
these are rights of all people qua human
beings but on the other hand we have all
of these formulations of human right
rights are made out of a particular
cultural religious perspective and that
may seem to create a certain form of
attention a particular thing is claimed
as universal and I think that's what the
debates are often often about because
from a particular perspective it is
formulated what rights of human beings
Kwak Hyunjoo to be and i think a given
way of formulating rights depends partly
on what we in this course have been
calling accounts of self social
relations and the good so you may affirm
the same right but depending on your
broader account of reality you may mean
different things by that and i think and
maybe we can discuss this later on
there's something like religious rights
you can see that in in religious rights
freedom of exercise the religious rights
can be understood or freedom to choose
one's own religion now if you have a
freedom of exercise understanding then
you have an understanding I think of the
self of an individual or LED or already
defined in some significant way by
social relations Catholic Jew or Muslim
and communities having some stake in the
self being part of that net network of
particular relations and then having
difficulty with that person wants to
wants to leave if you have understanding
of religious rights as rights of choice
the self is then situated within
communities maybe is also partly shaped
by then but self is fundamentally
independent of those understood as
independent of those communities free to
define itself over against any given
community so the this is how particular
accounts of self social relations in the
good shape what we understood by humor
right now when we talk about
universality I think that is and from a
particular perspective it's it's
significant issue is how do we negotiate
between competing Universal claims and
that's one of the issue that of issues
that has been brought up in our
discussion and in a sense we know how to
do that on a national levels right
we have vigorous debates you'd serve
reproductive rights issue can be can be
given as an example we have vigorous
public debates that hopefully clarify
issues maybe they muddled them a little
bit but nonetheless there is a
back-and-forth in the large political
arena then we vote right and then move
on in such such a way a significant
issue for us a central issue for us how
do we negotiate complete competing
Universal claims at the global level
that's that's that's a challenge
now next point that I wanted to bring up
is a relationship between religion and
rights we are not here simply to talk
about the importance of rights within
the globalized setting and a difficulty
to formulating those but how religion
plays into that that that issue and
we've seen in our reading a number of
different texts that we've read address
that issue one perspective might be that
we're deep might be that we are dealing
here with competing moral universes abu
alfadil recall has said the tensions
between convictional systems of religion
and human rights he said can be pruned
this way which of these two generalized
and objectified systems warrants
deference and which constitutes the
ultimate frame of reference right which
is the ultimate one that this is
competing moral universes we've seen
others who suggested those are
subordinated moral claims theology or
faith States ultimate in general norms
human rights rights reflection
articulated specific norms that are to
be subordinated to those and then we'll
seen also a certain complementarity
accounts of that and I think John's
account that we have read
is in part one that subordinates and
partly also emphasizes the
complementarity if I read John's account
rightly so that's one area of
relationship between religion and rights
what Trump's what in some sense and or
how the relationship is to be construed
but another area is is the question of
justification and motivation
justification of rights and motivation
for observance of Rights and I think
that's a very important issue human
rights culture and institutions can be
sustained only if they are seen as
justified if they're seen in some
significant sense as morally legitimate
prevalent custom can be argued is not
enough for justification this is simply
what we here do this is what we
civilized folks do or whatever that else
might be because it ends up being a
matter of imposition by various forms of
power and also writes when rights matter
the most the matter the most when much
is at stake and when much is the stake
the motivation to respect those rights
often needs justifications intellectual
justifications both to ourselves and
also to others so that justification of
Rights is already in and of itself
motivation for observing those rights
but religions provide quite apart from
justifications also other forms of
motivation for respect of human rights
respect for rights of others demands
care of others I mean respectful wants
own rights or claiming one's own rights
doesn't it it requires only sufficient
amount of self-centeredness right and
standing up on one's own rights but
human rights culture will thrive if each
of us is not simply concerned about our
own rights but rights of others as well
and that presumes care for the other
person for the rights of the others and
care for others is something that most
of the religion tradition religious
traditions feel that they inculcate
they're not the only groups that
inculcate that but they certainly do
so that's the question of of the
importance of the issue but there's also
a question which Nick Walters no Ezra
has Nick Walters of peace has raised and
that is is non religious justification
of Rights possible right and non
religious justifications of rights they
primarily run through capacities or
normal functioning you have certain kind
of capacities which make you a candidate
for being bearer of Rights or your
normal functioning of those capacities
make you a candidate for being a bearer
of those rights Nick has argued as you
have seen in that text and Nick by the
way it's going to be with us next week
sorry two weeks next week when we meet
all right but this which will be in two
in two weeks and he's gonna be part of
our discussions about liberal democracy
but we're reading his text on on human
rights
he's argues he has argued that these
accounts capacity based or normal
functioning based justification of human
rights well they don't justify human
rights rights of human beings who are
human they justify rights of certain
humans with certain functions and
therefore they're not broad enough to
justify in the to to give account of the
notion of human rights Nick has argued
that we need religious justifications of
human rights God as endowing human
beings with certain inalienable rights
now he's clarified his position and
sense that he says well sometimes even
religious justification of human rights
in the end amount to capacities
justifications God has given you certain
capacities on the virtue of these
capacities you have rights and Nick says
no that's not going to work and that's a
longer work exactly for the same reason
while secular capacities accounts of
human rights don't work because they
don't cover all instances of human
beings but only those who have these
types of capacities and Nick's argument
is that God's love for human beings
attachment to human beings in some way
relationship concrete relationship to
human being
bestows upon people in alienable rights
and he's a good example you will recall
if you read this text my favorite one is
a teddy bear examples so what gives
birth to a particular teddy bear for a
kid well a history of attachment to that
teddy bear and that teddy bear
may not win any award in the context for
the nicest of all teddy bears indeed it
may be all torn up and and in complete
disrepair but nonetheless that's the
most favorite teddy bear of all teddy
bears for that child that's the image
for Nick Wald restore the relationship
between God and human beings which then
grants and gives bestows value and
therefore also rights to human beings
those are the rough summary of some of
the things that we've been reading in
our text as well as issues that have
surfaced in our discussions but now to
expand this discussion we have with us
to two guests and I will ask first
professor whit a from Emory to address
us for 15 minutes and then professor
Clark from our own gal here well thank
you very much professor Wolff I'm good
afternoon to each of you it's great to
be back here at Yale too and enjoy the
very warm weather that you've put on for
me coming from the south I look forward
to having a robust discussion together
today on some of the fundamentals of
faith and freedom and in the article
that was circulated to you and in the
brief remarks today I'd like to make the
argument that faith is essential to
freedom and that religion is critical to
human rights
this year we're celebrating the 60th
anniversary of the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights and it's hard but
important to remember that this document
was born out of desperation in the
aftermath of World War two out of
painful recognition that both
Christianity and the Enlightenment had
failed to deliver on their promises in
the middle of the 20th century there is
no second coming of Christ promised
right
Christiane's no heavenly city of reason
promised by enlightened libertarians no
withering away of the state promised by
enlightened socialists instead there was
world war gulags in the holocaust of
vile and evil fascism irrationalism and
totalitarianism to which Christianity
and the Enlightenment seemed to have no
cogent response or effective deterrence
the Universal Declaration was an earnest
attempt to codify and to fill out what
are the core ingredients of a world
faith to fill a spiritual void it was an
attempt to harvest from the traditions
of Christianity and the Enlightenment
and other faith communities the
rudimentary elements of a new faith and
a new law that would unite a badly
broken World Order the proud claims of
article 1 of the declaration that all
men are born free and equal in rights
and dignity and are endowed with reason
and conscience expounded the primitive
truths of the tradition but with little
basis in post-war world reality freedom
and equality were hard to find anywhere
reason and conscience had just blatantly
betrayed themselves in the gulags
battlefields and death camps though
desperate and origin the human rights
movement grew precociously in the
decades following World War two the
United Nations issued a number of
landmark documents on human rights in
the 1950s and 1960s especially the Great
1966 covenants on Civil and Political
Rights and on social cultural and
economic rights and elaborated their
basic provisions in a number of follow
up declarations and conventions and
understandings on issues of genocide of
violence of torture and of gender and
racial discrimination in a variety of
forums of public life various nation
states pressed their own human rights
movements in a variety of discrete ways
in America the rights revolution issued
a powerful grassroots civil rights
movement and a welter of landmark cases
and statutes that made real sometimes
for the first time the guarantees of the
Bill of Rights and the 14th amendment in
Africa and Latin America it produced
agitation and eventually revolt against
colonial and Otto
kradic rule academics throughout the
world produced a prodigious new
literature urging constant reform and
expansion of the human rights regime
within a generation human rights had
become what the New York Times in 1973
called for the first time the new civic
faith of the post-war World Order
Christian Jewish and various other
religious communities participated
actively as midwives in the birth of
this modern rights revolution and
special religious rights protections
were at first actively pursued and
instantiated individual religious groups
issued bold confessional statements and
manifestos on human rights shortly after
World War two several denominations and
budding ecumenical bodies joined in the
cultivation of human rights at the
international level the free church
tradition in particular played a
critical role in the civil rights
movement in America as did Christian
Democratic Catholic movements in Europe
and in Latin America and in parts of
francophone Africa but after expressing
some initial interest leaders of the
rights revolution consigned religious
groups and their unique religious rights
claims to a lower and lower priority
freedom of speech and press parity of
race and gender provision of work and
welfare captured most of the energy and
emoluments of the rights revolution
after the 1960s and early 1970s academic
inquiries and activist interventions
into religious rights and their abuses
became increasingly intermittent and
isolated new constitutional laws emerged
in the United States and in Western
Europe that began to demand that laws
and legal instruments be grounded in
secular purposes and directed the
secular ends in order to pass
constitutional muster the rights
revolution both in international law
and in a variety of domestic laws seemed
to be passing and religion by and this
deprecation of the special roles and the
special rights of religions in the last
third of the 20th century or so has
introduced a number of distortions and
ooh the current theory of human rights
that tends to dominate discussions today
first without religion many rights are
cut from their roots the right to
religion the great German jurist York
Jelena crowed a century ago is the
mother of many other rights for the
religious individual the right to
believe and to exercise that belief
leads ineluctably to the rights to
assemble to speak through travel to
worship to proselytize to educate to
parents and other actions taken on the
direct foundation of those beliefs for
the religious group the right to exist
invariably involves rights to corporate
organization group property collective
worship organized charity parochial
education freedom of press autonomy of
governance transnational contracts and
much more to ignore religious rights is
often to overlook the conceptual source
of many other individual and
associational rights and it's also to
ignore the historical source of many of
our most cherished constitutional
freedoms
it's an instructive anecdote for example
that by 1650 every one of the rights
that would eventually appear in the
American Bill of Rights of 1789 had
already been fully theoretically
formulated and defended by Christian
writers who were elaborating what they
consider to be the essential correlative
rights of the Cardinal right to freedom
of conscience and freedom of exercise
and if one looks in the post colonial
post autocratic regimes oftentimes the
formulation of the religious rights of
the individual and the religious rights
of the group provide the constitutional
traction for the elaboration of a
variety of correlative rights that are
attached thereto and eventually
constitutionally and Stan's
second without religion the regime of
human rights is in danger of becoming
infinitely expandable the classic faiths
of the world community adopt and
advocate human rights in parts in order
to protect religious duties a religious
individual or a religious Association
has rights to exist
axé not in the abstract but in order to
discharge discrete duties defined by
their faith commitments and faith
communities rights and duties properly
belong together
in most religious traditions to speak of
one without the other is ultimately
destructive rights without duties to
guide them quickly become claims of
self-indulgence duties without rights to
exercise them quickly become sources of
deep guilt religious traditions amongst
others offer some of the best examples
of the organic linkage between rights
and duties and thereby put a natural
check and balance on the limitless
expansion of human rights into simple
into a simple gaggle of ungrounded
whimsical wishes and wants that have no
real ontological foundation and no real
chance of becoming real in practice
third without religion the state is
given an exaggerated role to play as the
guarantor of human rights the simple
state versus individual dialectic of
many modern human rights theories leaves
it to the state to protect provide and
vindicate rights of all sorts in reality
the state is not and cannot be so Amna
competent as the failed socialist
experiments of the 20th century have
tragically shown us numerous mediating
structures or spheres of justice stand
between the state and the individual
religious communities prominently
amongst them religious institutions or
Communities amongst many others play a
vital role in the cultivation and in the
realization of many types of rights they
can create the conditions and sometimes
the prototypes for some of the first
generations civil and political rights
they can provide a critical and in some
communities the principal means to meet
second-generation rights of education
health care childcare labor employment
artistic opportunities and much more and
religious communities offer some of the
deepest insights into the norms of
creation stewardship and servant
that lie at the heart of what we now
call third generation rights of peace
orderly development environmental
protection